if you missed the glory days of Tony
Hawk's Pro Skater there's a glimmer of
hope for you
the legendary border is looking into a
new game and it's not coming from
Activision he said as much in an
interview with skateboarding magazine
jenkum it's too early to confirm any
details or even if the game will
actually happen but Tony says he's happy
with the studio he's partnered with he
stated I'm potentially working on
something but it's so early I couldn't
talk about it I don't have any contracts
signed but it's exciting I feel like
it's with the right people so I should
know more in the next couple months
hopefully the hawk fares better this
time around since the last game in his
series Pro Skater 5 got a 3 out of 10
from GameSpot back in 2015 in the
meantime you can spot Tony in our famous
directors early work video over on
GameSpot universe he appeared in a
coca-cola commercial directed by none
other than JJ Abrams no joke to keep up
with Tony Hawk's new game you're already
in the right place